[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so what were you doing in 1995 hands up
if you're alive in 1995
okay good hands up you're on the
internet already okay a few good hands
up if you're getting paid to work on the
internet like commercially No a couple
of hands okay
1995 this browser Netscape Navigator 2
was released and amongst other things
did include a little language you might
have heard of called JavaScript now you
might be thinking why at a conference
where people are talking about the
future of JavaScript future front-end
development I'm talking about a 20 year
old browser mostly just seemed like a
fun idea kind of look back and try and
implement something that we might build
today in the browser in a old browser
that wasn't really designed for it and
so really just a bit of nostalgia
because I was kind of around for not
quite this early but early enough mostly
though I'm getting old and you kids
these days don't know how good you've
got it with all the dev tools and
everything you've got access to it my
journey with JavaScript started my first
job out of university probably about
1999 and commonly we use JavaScript to
implement this kind of navigation you
couldn't do this with CSS at the time
you had to use JavaScript this is
actually one I found on web archive that
I built probably about 2002 or so and so
when I started that first job one of my
co-workers had built this library that
could work in all the browser's we have
to support which at the time would have
been like IA 5 ie6 netscape for Netscape
6 or with slightly different ways of
doing dynamic content and so it was
really impressive
just like how much effort you had to put
in to get that working but all that
still was five years after Netscape
Navigator 2 so to understand why we're
going to have limitations when we try
and implement modern techniques in this
old browser it's worth looking back at
what this browser what JavaScript was
created for in the first place even
though it's in the name JavaScript has
very little to do with Java was just
really Netscape wanted to take advantage
of the popularity of Java at the time
with Java applets and they got a
trademark agreement with Sun to use the
Java name during development javascript
was actually called mocker initially and
then live script in the first navigator
betas before it finally came out as
javascript the Netscape 2 documentation
described JavaScript as a compact object
based scripting language for developing
client and server internet applications
that's what I found interesting I didn't
realize this that server internet
applications were actually something
that was intended for JavaScript from
the beginning so Netscape had something
called Netscape Enterprise Server and as
part of that there was a component
called livewire which let you write
server-side JavaScript it was more like
PHP than no j-f in that you had a HTML
page with a server tag and in that
server tag you could write the
JavaScript that would be evaluated on
the server to make database calls and
things like that but that kind of died
away with Netscape Enterprise Server and
it wasn't for another whether it is 10
15 years until back in JavaScript became
a thing again mostly what javascript was
used for was performed elevation as now
back then Network round trips were
expensive potentially and so anytime you
could save the user by telling them
they'd fill in the form incorrectly
was very helpful and so at the time
though you couldn't do any nice
client-side stuff you basically had to
pop up an alert to tell them what they'd
filled in so I didn't want to just do
something aim for something simple so I
wanted to set myself a goal to try and
build something in Netscape 2 that I
knew was going to be challenging and so
I decided to choose to do MVC mainly
because to-do lists are familiar for
everyone for those not familiar with to
do MVC it's coming out near project
started by a teaser just spoke and it's
basically a repository of to do MVC
basis to do lists implemented in various
frameworks I knew I wasn't going to be
able to get it to look like this or I
wasn't even sure how how I was going to
be able to get in terms of functionality
but I gave it a shot anyway
so I faced some early challenges before
I even started working on the to-do list
first of all I have basically so I got
my virtual machine setup I got Netscape
running and one thing I couldn't do one
thing I want to do was just try and load
a script show an alert box just to make
sure everything was working and so I had
a web server running on the host machine
which is how I could still develop on my
Mac and just load pages on Windows and
so the life of me I just couldn't get it
to load like it would the script wasn't
loading looking my web server logs there
was no request for the script and I
wasn't sure was going on eventually
somewhere in the documentation I found
that the source attribute wasn't
actually supported for the script tag in
Netscape to ASCII all scripting had to
be in line
the next challenge was going to be that
that there was no Dom API there was no
way to rewrite elements that were on the
page or even access most elements on the
page basically Netscape like most
browsers would render the page you could
have script tags on the page while it
was rendering and write out dynamic
content but once the page was finished
if you say as a result of an event
handler or a set timeout you did another
document right then it would clear out
what was on the page and start a new
page
I just want to cheat by just having my
whole dynamic app being a document dot
write I didn't think that'd be fair so
before I talk about how I actually
implemented what I did let's just have a
look at how far I go so this is to do
MVC running in Netscape 2 so dynamic so
you can actually check and uncheck items
and the content updates you can add new
items I need to relax after this
filtering works you can clear the
completed items yeah so the basics are
there that's like that
so let's rather than just showing this
let's talk about how it was actually
implemented the key to all this was
frame sets for those not familiar with
frame sets and you may not be if you
haven't been doing web development for a
long time because it's now a deprecated
feature frame sets you can basically
instead of a body tag on a page you can
have a frame set
and in there you can define frames of
content to be loaded from different
sources it's essentially what evolved
into iframes eventually and along with
that you can net frame sets and you
could lay them out using these row and
column attributes so it was kind of like
the early days of CSS grid if you want
to think about it that way and so frame
sets were the key because I was working
at the Netscape to dock so this is the
documentation that Netscape provided for
JavaScript and it was used to frame set
so the navigation was on the left and
then the content was on the right but
one thing they had was down the bottom
these height content buttons when you
hit that button it would hide and show
it and that was dynamic and I thinking
how they do that and looking at the
source for that was what inspired my
solution so I built what's called a
pseudo dynamic app basically you have a
frame set and the state lives in the
frame set itself so in the script tag
you set up some JavaScript state then
they have two frames and the reason for
this another one of those things that
took me a while to work out was that you
need at least two frames otherwise a
frame set won't render at all and so the
content frame is the dynamic part it's
written out using a combination of
static HTML and document rights so to
have a quick look at that she got the
state and then you've got document dot
write tags that access the state from
the parent frame and then you've got say
a button and if you want to update
something in the state then you have an
event handler that calls a function in
the parent frame set now the key to it
is this this is effectively the
equivalent of document reload which
didn't exist and so basically we're
telling the content frame to reload
itself and when it reloads itself it'll
read the current state and so that's how
the application works now when you think
about it you've got the state the state
gets reflected by the view and any
actions that happen on the view get fed
back into the state so essentially what
we've done is implemented the flux model
for Netscape to
[Applause]
but apart from just the challenge of how
to actually set up the architecture for
this there was some just challenges in
terms of limitations in the language and
limitations in the dev environment that
I want to take you through so studies
was error handling when a JavaScript
error occurred you'll just get this
modal pop-up you couldn't click outside
it was useful I could told you what line
the error was on told you what the error
was conveniently they used a lot of
keyword reserves a lot of keywords from
C and Java so const was already reserved
back in 1995 which is convenient now and
yeah when you dismissed it if there was
another error then you would get the
next error would pop up and so for
example if you visit google.com in
Netscape 2 you get this whole bunch of
errors from their analytics code and you
basic after you can't really tell from
the framerate of the gift but I'm
basically just missing dialogue after
dialogue after dialogue just to be able
to see the page underneath so these days
when we develop we're used to writing to
the console like we just want to quickly
output a state of a variable at a
particular point in time we use the
console Netscape didn't have a console
there was a Java console for Java
applets - right - but there was no
JavaScript console so basically instead
we would use alerts you'd basically
pop-up alert and with the contents of
your variable at a particular point in
time and sometimes this was the only way
to debug something in case of event
handlers there was some event handlers
that some event handlers would just fail
silently they wouldn't even pop up the
standard error dialog so you had to
basically put an alert after every line
of your event handler and try and work
out which one fired last and from there
work out what the actual error was at
least you knew which line it was on
probably the other thing we're used to
when developing applications these days
is being able to use like the elements
panel in dev tools and C or the elements
on the page what current state they're
in but all you had was view source in
there - gate - and it wasn't even view
source
of a frame you can only view the source
of the page itself which wasn't very
useful when all the page contained was a
frame set and so a common technique a
common technique when building dynamic
content with document rate would be to
put the string in a variable first alert
that and you have to manually inspect to
see where you've missed a bracket or
quote or something that was causing it
to render incorrectly and potentially
you would if it was a big string I
remember times copying the contents of
the alert and pasting it into a document
where I could use like HTML tidy or
something to try and format the HTML to
see where I'd missed miss some bit of
HTML next challenges were around the
language itself so there's no short
object shorthand so it meant creating a
state a nested state took a lot of
verbosity and the other thing you might
notice there is that my two dues aren't
an array they're an object and it looks
like an array like it's numerically
indexed and goal length but the reason
for that was JavaScript one didn't even
actually contain an array data type it
didn't actually come until JavaScript
1.1 which was like nine months after
Netscape to the documentation mentioned
this had said just use objects they're
similar enough to arrays basically and
provide like a little helper function
for creating an array from like a set of
arguments there was no the only way you
could declare a function was globally so
you couldn't declare a function inside a
function you can declare an anonymous
function you couldn't have a function as
a result of an event a callback for like
a set timeout so that was pretty
limiting one workaround for for example
to set timeouts and things like that was
you'd use the eval syntax of set timeout
with IP Goodpaster string and that
string would be eval after the timeout
had expired the object model in Netscape
2 was also very limited as I mentioned
Netscape was really designed for form
validation was just so javascript was
intended mainly to perform validation
and smaller things like that so it's
reflected in the object model you
basically attacked as access to forms
and within those forms just the various
elements there was no arbitrary access
to any element on the page
similarly the event model was quite
limited
there was no add eventlistener you
couldn't programmatically add event that
was still five years away and I guess
with inline scripting it wasn't much
benefit to being able added
programmatically and the event handlers
themselves were limited so for example
now where you might expect a mouse-over
to work on any element that have a size
and is visible in Netscape 2 it would
only work for an anchor but it wouldn't
work for an image for example anybody
had to just look at the docks to see
what elements events were supported
where obviously the last challenge with
styling so I had to use tables for
layout although that really didn't go
away for at least another 10-15 years if
you've had to work on email templates
you may have even written a table last
week for layout and colors were fairly
limited so you could set basically you
could set the background color of the
body but you couldn't even set the
background color of a table or a table
cell which is why the layout of that
to-do list was just all white pretty
much so basically the or you had access
to so in terms of styling was the font
tag and font tag you could set the size
and the color of the text and again it
was limited in that the size wasn't a
pixel size it was basically a fixed
number like 1 to 7 you could set it to
and that was basically decided by the
browser what those seven sizes were you
can also use relative sizes so
plus/minus based on the size of the
containing element they might notice I
said there you could set the font size
and font color one thing you couldn't
set is the font face so the font face
attribute wasn't actually part of the
HTML 3.2 spec even so Netscape didn't
let you actually change the font the
only reason you're not looking at Times
New Roman right now is because I've just
changed the default browser font to
something that's a bit more pleasant
and so yeah the face attribute was
something that Microsoft actually added
as a custom attribute initially in their
browser so powerful note there was a
couple little quirks I just want I
wanted to show you was like a little
memory corruption issue I ran into if
you really rapidly click on those items
you suddenly get memory leaks from
outside of your page like the URL or
sometimes HTTP header or something so
that was fun and at one point I think I
had something where if I didn't force
the encoding to utf-8 I would just get
like weirdness with the font but that
may have just been a VirtualBox issue so
we've kind of taken Netscape to as far
as we can take it I want to kind of move
forward at least a little bit in time to
a browser that was supposed to support
building dynamic applications that
browser wasn't Netscape 3 Netscape 3
came out pretty quickly after Netscape 2
had some JavaScript improvements like
arrays but it didn't have any Dinah I
had the same programming model for
dynamic content so instead let's move on
to next cake fall so Netscape 4 was the
first netscape browser to support what
was called at the time dynamic HTML did
anyone own a copy of this book at any
point in time there's a few I didn't
know in the third edition but I looked
back at my Amazon purchase history and
this is like one of the first books live
aboard in like 99 when I started working
and the way Netscape implemented dynamic
HTML was through the use of pelea tag so
layers were an element that you could
reposition you could modify its content
you could resize it so finally you could
sort of build some dynamic dynamic
content on your page without jumping
through in theory too many hoops so
let's have a look what the to-do list
apart from just with layers and with all
the other features in there care for
what it looks like so you have a looking
a little bit nicer we've got different
background colors leaves with a little
key line in between items source tool
tables for layout mostly but it is using
layers as well so we can still add an
item
yeah all that work so I'm not going to
go through all this part again so let's
talk about how the implementation in
Netscape 4 differed from what I did in
that scape 2 so now instead of using
frame sets we're using layers to
implement this now something that's not
reflected in these slides was that I
built like a little component
abstraction around the layers so I could
have essentially like the application
was an object and had child objects for
the different components or that knew
about their layer and could re render
their own layer in terms of the data
model it still looked pretty similar in
terms of the state they maintained in
the parent and the children being able
to re render themselves so you can see
their layers basically they implement
their own document each layer is its own
HTML document so your three years
document right to update a layer and you
still face the same restrictions in that
as soon as you start writing to it it
resets the content that's already there
but because these smaller components it
means probably not as bad that you've
got basically fast HTML in strings
everywhere and so I've kind of used like
a again to use the analogy like a
reactive type model where when I want to
update I just basically told all the
childhood components to update with the
current state and they you had a
rerender themselves so what challenges
whether when building for Netscape 4 so
first we already talked about briefly
about what the challenges were with
layers now the big thing about layers
was they're always absolutely positioned
so you couldn't have a layer inside
another element you could have a layer
inside a layer that you couldn't have a
layer like within the layer of an
existing page so for example that
example I gave before with the
navigation menu in your normal HTML
layer you just leave a gap and then you
would absolutely position the layers to
fit in there the challenge with that was
that for example for a to-do list which
is dynamically size depending on the
number of items you need to have a way
for those components to be able to say
how tall they are based on
number items they've got said if you
want a position like the footer
underneath for example and obviously
debugging is difficult as I mentioned
before there's no elements panel student
existed in Netscape four and so it meant
if say a layer disappeared off-screen
you have no way of telling why you
couldn't tell if it was because you'd
set the exposition incorrectly or
whether you'd hidden it inadvertently or
some other some other bug so again it
was a lot of manual alerts and waiting
for errors and things like that
the layer API kind of looked like forms
before so we still couldn't just
arbitrary get any elements you can only
get layers by name or by ID and once you
had access to a layer you can access
this document to which document property
you could set the attribute sub layers
are kind of like almost like CSS styling
type properties and also have these
convenience functions for things like
relative positioning relative sizing
which could be useful at times and if
you really want to go crazy and you had
nested layers then you could access them
like this probably not recommended
though and one thing I wanted to point
out there was for visibility it was
actually wasn't a boolean it was three
states so you can have hide show and
inherit I think was the other one
debugging in Netscape 4 wasn't much
easier but it was a little bit easier no
longer did you get a modal alert that
would block what the page you would
instead get told there was a JavaScript
error and p-type JavaScript colon have
suggested there you'll get the
JavaScript console now this wasn't the
console as we used to today it was
fairly limited but it would show you all
the errors that had occurred not just
the first one that probably a bad
example but if you had like a set
timeout or set interval that was firing
every 100 milliseconds and throwing an
error it would eventually tell you that
there was too many errors and that would
stop processing them though this
JavaScript type in that you typ in an
evaluate arbitrary JavaScript but there
was limits to what it could do as well
you typed in window or you got was
object window there was no way to
inspect the properties of an object
unless you knew what they were in
advance if you typed in window location
then you would get the location of the
JavaScript console not the page you
opened it from which wasn't necessarily
very helpful and so lastly styling in
Netscape 4 was a little bit better and
it was the first Netscape version to
implement CSS but it wasn't really CSS
had a lot of issues
what made it was CSS basically the
history of that is Netscape had
originally been working towards
implementing JavaScript style sheets and
I think there's a talk on JavaScript
style sheets later on this conference
and and they were hoping javascript
associates what was going to be
standardized but in CSS got standardized
and they have to have scrambled to
provide the implementation of CSS in
Netscape 4 and so it shows with the kind
of bugs that that occur this wasn't
necessarily a bug but a limitation at
the time was only one class name third
class attribute so you couldn't compose
classes which meant that there was a lot
of repetition of styles if you wanted to
have different variants of a class
inheritance was buggy or missing at
times if you set the color of the body
text if you create as a table then in
the table the color would be reset again
so a lot of duplication and the fonts as
well
lastly the styles were just buggy in
general like padding on that last list
item and it's added the padding to the
body but it hasn't actually
resented ver bullet so just to wrap up
what have we learnt nothing you can
probably apply to your day job but
hopefully what you've gotten out of this
is an appreciation for just how
difficult it was to work with these
early browsers basically that there was
a lot of challenges involved and so if
you're around in the early days of the
web and you saw some cool websites you
can hopefully have an appreciation of
just how much work would have gone into
making those work right and just in
general I really want to personally and
hopefully from everyone here thankful
the people that work on developer tools
probably a few of them in this room it's
really awesome the tools we have today
and it just makes it so much easier to
work with the web so with that this one
is done and thank you
you